- [Voiceover] We're asked
to subtract negative six X
to the fourth minus
three X squared Y squared
plus Y to the fourth from
two X to the fourth minus
eight X squared Y squared
mins Y to the fourth.
And I encourage you to pause
this video and give it a try.
Alright, let's work through it together.
So We're gonna subtract
this green polynomial
from this magenta one.
So we can rewrite this as,
we're to actually
perform it we could write
two X to the fourth
minus eight X squared Y squared
minus Y to the fourth
minus, and I'm gonna
write this in parenthesis,
give us some space,
minus negative six X to the fourth
minus three X squared Y squared
plus five Y to the fourth.
So notice, I'm subtracting
this green polynomial
in two variables from
this magenta polynomial
in two variables.
Which is exactly what
it says to do up here.
So what's this going to be?
Well I can just rewrite the magenta part.
We're gonna have two X to the fourth
minus eight X squared Y squared
minus Y to the fourth.
And then I can distribute
this negative sign.
So if we say the negative of
negative six X to the fourth,
that's gonna be positive
six X to the fourth.
So that's gonna go positive
And then the negative of negative
three X squared Y squared
is going to be positive
three X squared Y squared.
So plus three X squared Y squared.
And then last but not least,
we have a negative, or we're subtracting
positive five Y to the fourth.
So that's going to be
subtracting five Y to the fourth,
or negative five Y to the fourth.
And now we can try to simplify.
So let's first look at
this term right over here.
We have two X to the fourths.
And what we could look for is
another X to the fourth term.
And we see it right over here.
So we have two X to the fourths
and we can add that to
six X to the fourths.
So what's that going to be?
Well if I have two of something,
and then I add another
six of that something, that's going to be
eight X to the fourths, two plus six.
Two X to the fourth
plus six X to the fourth
is going to be eight
X to the fourth power.
And now we have this X
squared Y squared term.
We could say we're
subtracting eight of them.
And over here we're adding three of these
X squared Y squared terms.
So we could add these coefficients.
If we're taking away eight,
but we're adding three
we could view this as negative
eight X squared Y squareds
plus three X squared Y squareds.
Well what's negative eight plus three?
Well that's going to be negative five.
Negative five X squareds Y squareds.
So that's that term.
Let me write that a little bit neater.
That's this term
right over here, don't forget
to include this sign here.
This is you're subtracting
eight X squared Y squareds,
you could do that as negative
eight X squared Y squared
plus three X squared Y squared.
And then last but not least,
you're subtracting one Y to the fourth,
and then you're subtracting
five more Y to the fourths.
So what's that going to be?
You could view this as
negative one Y to the fourth
minus five Y to the fourths.
Well that's going to be
negative one minus five
is negative six.
Negative six Y to the fourths.
And we're done, we have subtracted
this from that.